Ja.
Also, Bits und qubits
werden die grundlegenden Rechenbausteine sein,
mit denen wir
komplexe Probleme der Welt angehen können.
Lass uns also den Unterschied zwischen ihnen verstehen
und herausfinden, woher die Stärke der qubits kommt.
Wenn wir uns die linke Seite anschauen,
sehen wir eine Darstellungsweise – wir werden diese Diagramme
durchgehend in der Präsentation verwenden,
um die Stärke zu verdeutlichen. Wir sehen eine Kugel
und zwei Punkte: wenn der Punkt am Nordpol liegt,
steht das für eine Null, am Südpol für eine Eins.
Das ist ein klassisches Bit mit zwei Zuständen. Ein qubit hingegen ist die
Informationseinheit in der Quantenwelt.
Und hier haben wir es mit einer Kugel zu tun,
die sowohl Null als auch Eins darstellen kann.
Wir können sie in diesem Superpositionszustand halten.
Wir haben einen besonderen Trick, der uns zur Verfügung steht:
Nicht nur können wir sie irgendwo auf der Kugel positionieren,
sondern stell dir vor, dass jeder dieser Zustände
wie ein kleiner Mond ist,
der sich auf der Kugel befindet – und wir können den Mond drehen.
Hier siehst du,
dass die untere Kugel leicht gedreht wurde,
weshalb du ein bisschen Blau
und Pink siehst. Wir könnten ihn auch ganz durchdrehen –
hier ist eine Drehung um hundertachtzig Grad.
Wir haben also diesen Begriff der Phase. Die Quantenmechanik bietet uns
drei Superkräfte, die in den qubits zum Ausdruck kommen:
die Kraft der Superposition,
die Kraft der Interferenz
und die Kraft der Verschränkung.
Schauen wir uns diese genauer an. Das Prinzip der Superposition ist eigentlich
recht einfach zu verstehen.
Der Stern auf der linken Seite steht
entweder für Nordpol Null oder Südpol Eins.
Wenn wir diese beiden Zustände addieren,
erhalten wir ein qubit in Superposition, das gleichzeitig
Null und Eins ist – sowohl Nord als auch
Süd. Das rechte Diagramm zeigt dasselbe,
aber jetzt machen wir einen kleinen Trick:
Wir wenden ein gate an – ein Quanten-gate.
Was wir hier gemacht haben – erinnere dich –
wir können jetzt diese kleinen Monde
drehen, richtig?
Also haben wir ihn um hundert-
achtzig Grad gedreht und haben jetzt eine Eins.
Wenn wir nun Null plus Eins addieren, erhalten wir
einen Superpositionszustand,
aber beachte, dass er sich unterscheidet:
Beim linken haben wir
immer noch Null und Eins, aber jetzt mit einem gedrehten Zustand
für die Eins. Das wird sehr mächtig sein,
um dann eine zweite wirklich interessante Eigenschaft zu nutzen, nämlich
das Prinzip der Interferenz.
Das ist keine Operation, die uns in der klassischen
Bitwelt zur Verfügung steht. In diesem Beispiel haben wir
links Null und Eins, plus
diesen neuen Zustand, den wir erstellt haben,
der ebenfalls Null und Eins ist,
aber mit diesem gedrehten Mond. Wenn wir das jetzt machen,
können wir diese beiden Zustände interferieren lassen,
und beachte, was dabei passiert:
Wir haben den Eins-Zustand ausgelöscht
und sind mit dem Null-Zustand übrig geblieben.
Das konnten wir, weil wir die Zustände interferieren ließen.
Die nächste Frage, die sich uns stellt,
ist: Wie viele Zustände können wir erzeugen?
Das Schöne an der Quantenwelt ist, dass wir exponentiell viele
Zustände erzeugen können. Schauen wir uns ein System mit
fünf qubits an. In diesem Fall stellen wir diese qubits
als unabhängige qubits dar – du siehst sie links
als Nullen und Einsen, die multipliziert werden. Wir haben fünf
davon, sodass die Anzahl der Zustände, die wir erzeugen können –
beim Quantencomputer, dargestellt auf der Kugel rechts –
gleich zwei hoch
der Anzahl der qubits ist. In diesem Fall sind es fünf,
also zwei hoch fünf ergibt zweiunddreißig Zustände.
Wir sehen also zweiunddreißig dieser kleinen Monde.
Beachte, dass wir in diesem Fall keine
Phase eingebaut haben – sie sind alle pink. Die Stärke der
Verschränkung in der Quantenwelt liegt darin,
dass wir jetzt Zustände erzeugen können,
wie den, der rechts dargestellt ist,
wo wir diese Kombinationen aus Pink
und Blau haben – und dieser Zustand lässt sich nicht
als unabhängiges Produkt
dieser fünf qubits beschreiben.
Da wir zweiunddreißig Zustände haben,
sagt uns das etwas sehr Tiefgründiges.